Även förra året, men nu har vi verkligen tagit bort globalt, vilket är sjukt kul.
Så nu är Sverige ungefär 8 procent.
Oj, det är ju bra jobbat.
Vilka är de största marknaderna?
USA är den största marknaden.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Christine Haas till podden som driver och har grundat Sisterly Tribe.
Du kommer lite med andan i halsen.
Du har haft ett par intensiva veckor här bakom.
Hur är läget Christine?
Det är superbra.
Det är kul att vara här.
Kul att snacka med dig, men det har absolut varit intensivt.
Det har varit en full fart i hela året, men också de senaste veckorna.
Helgen var ju Palmo hade en liten break, vilket var välbehövligt.
Vi åkte till London i tisdag morgon, var där i ungefär 24 timmar.
Idag är vi som på kontoret, och lansering nästa vecka på Black Week.
Det är lag i flyttar, och det är massa grejer framåt också.
Full fart, men kul att vara här.
Vad gör man på 24 timmar i London?
Vad hinner man med?
Det var framförallt att vi hade ett möte med Selfridges, för vi har börjat sälja våra produkter på Selfridges i London, så vi hade ett möte med deras inköpsteam, och sen pratade jag lite med vår PR-tjej, och hon ska åka till LA nu på torsdag, så hon ska också med sig prover för att prata med potentiella wholesalekunder där.
Så det var framförallt för att komma dit för mötet och lämna alla prover.
Hur bra är Selfridges som kund?
Är det mest att det är lite coolt för en själv, eller är de bra på riktigt?
Tjänar ni några pengar på dem?
Ja, men de är jättebra.
De kommer aldrig att lyssna på denna podd, de fattar inte svenska.
Nej, sant, nej.
Det är ett väldigt starkt varumärke, så det är fantastiskt att ha sådana produkter där.
Men de har också en väldigt bra försäljning, de säljer väldigt mycket.
Så vi har snabbt blivit en väldigt stor kund på en väldigt kort tid, vilket är roligt och visst är det klart att kanske inte tjänar lika mycket pengar som på andra wholesalekunder, för det var inte jättelätt att förändra villkoren med dem, utan det var mer såhär, vi kör.
Det var inte så mycket förhandlingsutrymme, men det är klart att det är ändå en plusaffär.
Sen nämnde du att du träffade någon ansvarig för någonting som skulle åka till eller är det någon kollega eller är det någon ni bara jobbar med?
Ja men det är en PR-byrå som vi började jobba med för ett år sen ungefär.
Vi signade på Black Friday, hade första möte och signade.
Det är en tjej som har kontor i London, men också nu ska hon vara i LA i några veckor, åker till New York, så hon har mycket kontakter både i UK och i USA och även i mellanåsten.
Så jag hade möte med henne och hon hjälper även till lite grann med introduktion till vissa Holsir-kunder.
Nu när hon är i USA och i LA så kommer hon att ha möte med några som vill ha dialog med och visa produkterna.
Hur är det en sån där människa som jobbar med er?
Är de ultra extroverta och extremt trevliga eller är de mer, jag vet inte, hur är en sån där människa egentligen?
Kan man prata med honom på ett vanligt sätt?
Ja men absolut, hon är ju väldigt social och väldigt trevlig.
Man får väldigt mycket energi när man är med henne.
Hon har sjukt mycket idéer, mycket tankar och mycket kontakter.
Och en people person.
Du har alltid haft ganska mycket press.
Om man räknar artiklar eller omnämnanden per krona.
Det är som något sorts.
Jag vet inte om du gjorde det samma när du var barn, men då köpte man ju alkohol i FPK, du var fylla per krona.
Det var nytt.
Då var det den här tequila med röd hatt på, den låg bra till.
Men du har alltid varit väldigt bra på att få PR och omnämnanden och sånt.
Har det varit en strategi eller är det någonting som bara har hänt för att du är social och utåt?
Jag tror att det är lite både och.
Det har delvis varit en strategi att få bli omnämnd av olika anledningar.
När jag började så tror jag det är också för att min bakgrund är att jag kom från ett ganska stort bolag och hade varit inom odinget i så pass många år och varit med och byggt upp saker och helt plötsligt ta steget och lämna och bygga något eget.
Det är ganska ovanligt.
Så då klart att jag fick en del press på grund av det och sen så klart att man har jobbat.
Tänker vad kan vara en bra story eller hur kan man bygga upp det och även bygga mitt personliga varumärke.
Jag har varit ganska aktiv på LinkedIn och delat och med resan och delat liksom, ja men delat med resan och det har ju också varit bra för att både lyfta Sistly Tribe och lyfta mig.
Jag har fått kontakt av investerare delvis också via LinkedIn till exempel.
Men sen har vi också jobbat mycket med press för att positionera varumärket.
Så som det här år har vi fått fantastisk press.
Vi har varit i Forbes, vi har varit i Vogue, vi har varit i Gratia, InStyle, vi har varit i sjukt fantastisk press och det har ju varit jättebra också för varumärket att positionera oss tillsammans med Aloe, Lille Lemon, Viori och Lyx varumärken.
Det har ju såklart också hjälpt att få in wholesalekunder.
Tycker du att det är jobbigt när, om vi säger Forbes vet ju alla vad det är, en Vogue vet väl också alla i och för sig vad det är.
Men är det jobbigt att få press i sådana tidningar för att helt plötsligt blir det ju på riktigt.
Känner du att fan jag måste, nu får jag inte fucka upp.
Nu kan jag inte säga någonting dumt.
Tänker du på vad du säger när du sitter i sådana sammanhang?
Ja men det är såklart att, man tänker på vad man säger och hur man kommunicerar när man är i sådana sammanhang.
Jag fick till mig, när jag var på Babelum innan, och vi skulle in på bussen.
Jag blev tränad i mediahantering.
Vad sa de åt dig då?
Att du skulle svara inte på frågor, bara säga vad du vill?
Ja men precis ungefär så.
Nej absolut inte så.
Det var efter vi skulle in på bussen också, då blir det så himla viktigt att man får kommunicera om man inte får kommunicera.
Då var jag nästan vågad att inte säga någonting.
Men det som är härligt nu när jag har mitt egna bolag är att jag inte har någon annan som jag behöver få så till svar för på samma sätt.
Utan jag kan ju kommunicera...
Jag är liksom en vd eller styrelse som är såhär, det här får du inte säga eller det här kan du inte säga.
Så jag kan vara mycket friare i hur jag kommunicerar.
Har du någon slags alter ego-personlighet eller är du som du är?
Nej men jag skulle nog säga att jag är ganska mycket som jag är.
Finns det inga drag som du inte släpper fram?
Nej, det skulle jag nog inte säga.
Jag är väldigt glad, driven, mycket energi och framåt person.
Det är väl ungefär det jag kan framställa också, att jag har väldigt mycket energi.
Men när det är klart att man kommer hem ibland och man bara känner sig helt dränerad, då behöver vi också ditt egen tid.
Vi har ju hängt på några liknande event.
E-handelsvärlden är ju inte ultrastor, utan det blir ju sådär, man springer på.
Sen har vi nästan aldrig pratat sådär.
Vi har liksom sagt hej eller varit tillsammans, men vi har inte sett sådär jättemycket, men jag har ju sett att du är på många event.
Men eftersom du får mycket press och sånt, upplever du att folk förväntar sig en viss personlighet eller att de pratar med dig som att du ska fatta att, så hänvisar de till någonting som du sa för två år sedan och säger såhär, fan du minns väl inte jag att jag sa det där eller?
Nej, jag har nog inte tänkt, det är nog ingenting jag har tänkt på.
Men jag är ganska öppen som person.
Föreallt, jag brukar vara ganska öppen med att dela med mig av någon fråga, så hjälper jag till, jag tycker det är kul att hjälpa till och ge tips.
Eller jag vet att det var jättemånga som hört av sig om vilken PR-byrå har du jobbat med och då är jag alltid liksom såhär, jag har liksom inte gate-tippat på den informationen, utan jag vill hjälpa till och när jag kan hjälpa till så har jag inga problem med det.
Så jag skulle nog aldrig reflektera över det.
Och vi ska komma in här på Sisterly Tribe om en stund, men väldigt många människor vill ju givetvis bli omnämnda.
Det är ju fantastiskt att få den pressen som du har fått.
Har du några tips där hur man ska gå tillväga?
Ska man bara spämma journalister och beslutsfattare tills de pratar eller ska man bara gå ut på LinkedIn och skriva att här är jag!
Vad ska man göra liksom?
Ja men en bra fråga.
Jag brukar alltid fundera, jag har absolut inte spämma, man kontaktar ju journalister när man har någonting som man vill kommunicera.
Och då behöver det ju oftast vara någonting som man kanske inte har skrivit om tidigare.
Så det kan ju till exempel vara som ni har startat i City Tribe, eller till exempel relaserade på SelfieDest eller jag tog in kapital.
Det är ju olika typer av händelser som kan vara intressant, så då får man försöka hitta vad som kan vara en vinkel och hur man kan paketera det på ett bra sätt.
Så skriver man en liten pressrelease med någon rubrik och lite kort text och hoppas att man kan tycka att det är relevant.
Så kontaktar man redaktörer och kan se vilka som brukar skriva om den här typen av saker.
Så kontaktar man dem.
Sen jobbar man också på LinkedIn att man skriver om saker.
Där brukar man ju tänka, hur ska jag bygga upp någonting?
Eller är det samma sak, ska man lansera en produkt till exempel?
Då kanske man inte går ut med en gång och säger nu lanserar vi den här produkten.
Man kanske bygger upp en story.
Man bygger upp en resa.
Eller vad ska man säga?
Så att man kanske har det här, det här vill jag ha, det här vill jag kommunicera om.
Så kanske man kommunicerar på det olika steg.
Till exempel på LinkedIn.
Fan vad smart, jag har aldrig tänkt på det.
Kanske jag också borde ta till mig av.
Ja men du kör ju bara på ändå.
Ja det här kommer jag på idag.
Men det där var ett smart sätt, så borde man göra.
Okej, det var ju clean, snyggt.
Om vi tar Sisterly Tribe här, vad för oss som inte vet, eller jag vet väl för jag har ståkat företaget här nu i två veckor, men för folk som inte vet, vad gör ni och hur går det?
Vad vi gör, vi är ett värderingsdrivet wellnessbarumärke som designar och tar fram...
Det jag ville göra med varumärket var att kombinera skandinavisk design, bra kvalitet, bra passform, med community och att bygga någonting som inte bara handlar om produkter utan hur kan inspirera fler, framförallt kvinnor, att tro på sig själva, följa sin väg eller sina drömmar i livet, men också vara med och bidra till en mer ansvarsfull mordindustri.
Det gäller genom att vilka man jobbar med, säkerställa att de som producerar produkten har bra villkor, får en lön som de kan leva på, och blir omhändertagna, eller har bra villkor för de som syr, men också att vi jobbar med material som är ändå lite bättre mot miljön, men också som håller länge och som är mjuka och sköna på kroppen.
Så det var egentligen det som SISLTRIBE är.
Det går bra, det går framåt liksom.
Man kiggar på, det är ju en superkonkurrenshusat bransch, absolut.
Ni säljer liksom yoga-inspirerade kläder, är det så jag ska uttrycka det?
Ja men det är ju yoga, pilater, så mer liksom kring soft, mer soft movements.
Där det handlar om att wellness, det är inte bara att det går att träna för att bli snygg, utan det handlar också om att det går att träna för att vara bra, för att connecta med dig själv, ta hand om dig själv.
Så vi vill inspirera fler att elevate to self care movements.
Det är massa fraser där som jag inte tror någon i gym-kompanjets historia har sagt någonsin.
Hur sätter man igång då?
När du drog igång detta så tänkte du, nu ska jag bygga ett community.
Hur gjorde du för att inte bara skulle bli du som satt där på en sten och mediterade?
Hur börjar man?
Det första jag gjorde var att starta ett Instagram-konto.
Det här var 2020 då.
TikTok var inte riktigt lika stort då.
Det började vara lite grann men det var inte lika stort som det har blivit nu.
På den tiden var det mer Instagram.
Jag började med att starta ett Instagram-konto.
Vi hade inga produkter heller.
Säljare hade inte fått något samtidigt.
Det var kanske ett halvår innan lanseringen.
Så då började jag bygga rätt.
Så jag på Instagram skrev mer inspiration quotes.
Det var mycket inspiration men sen också lite behind the scenes.
Vi gjorde också vilka färger tycker ni om eller vilka produkter vill ni se.
Vi försökte skapa lite engagemang med de som började följa en.
Men också väldigt mycket i DM.
Man skickade DM till olika människor och connectade människor framförallt via DM.
Så det var väl innan lanseringen.
Och sen efter lanseringen var det dels att jobba mycket med gifting och att skicka ut produkterna till olika profiler.
Men jag har också jobbat väldigt mycket med att ha i olika event.
Så det gjorde jag väldigt mycket.
Så vi har haft både yoga-event och jag har stått och sålt på nån wellness-retreat i Hullviken.
Eller i Skarnör.
Jag bara tog bilen och hade alla produkter hemma och satt upp en rail och bockade åt hotell och var där och pratade med människor och sönde produkter.
Så det var mycket event och mycket...
Vi var ute bland folk och byggde varumärket.
Eller vad ska man säga?
Vi fick ut varumärket.
Är det Sverige som är den överlägset starkaste marknaden eller hur ser du?
Just nu är det inte det.
Det var redan första åren.
Men egentligen, och även förra året, men nu har vi verkligen tagit fart globalt vilket är sjukt kul.
Så nu är Sverige ungefär 8 procent.
Oj, ja det är ju bra jobbat.
Vilka är de största marknaderna?
USA är den största marknaden.
Och nu har UK blivit den största marknaden.
Och sen är det väl om Sverige, Tyskland, Schweiz, Mellanöstern har kommit igång väldigt bra.
Så det är väldigt spridda skurrar skulle jag säga just nu.
Vad är det som gör att du har, du har ju många konkurrenter eller även om det inte är konkurrenter, men folk som säljer saker som går att skicka, som har det som nån sorts våt dröm och kunna sprida sig globalt på det sättet.
Vad är det som har gjort att det har lyckats?
Det är inte så att åka dit och hålla ett yoga retreat.
Nej, men jag tror att jag väl alltid, från att jag, min vision med Sister Tribe har alltid varit att bygga ett globalt varumärke.
Jag vill ju bli nästa generations Lille Lämmun.
Och innan jag startade Sister Tribe, jag bodde i London i 15 år.
Och jag bodde även i USA och var del och satt upp det när Allsins lanserade det där.
Och även under tiden när jag var i London, så jobbade jag mycket med internationell expansion och globala marknader.
Så min vision har ju alltid varit att bygga ett globalt varumärke.
Och jag tror att...
Fan, det finns många människor som har det som vision men inte lyckas.
Nej men absolut, men så vi har ändrat också all kommunikation, vi har alltid kommunicerat på engelska.
Ett dag hade jag svensk hemsida, jag bara, vi skrotar det, det tar för mycket tid.
Vi kör alltid på engelska, så vi har alltid kommunicerat på engelska.
Alla annonser är alltid på engelska.
Alla mejl är alltid på engelska.
Men sen så tror jag också såklart att det är en global trend.
Hela wellness, pilates, yoga är framförallt ännu större eller starkare utanför Sverige än vad det är i Sverige.
Sen har vi också en lite dyrare, mer premiumprodukt.
Det finns en större målgrupp utanför Sverige som kan lägga 1 000-2 000 på ett par läggings.
De tycker också om det skandinaviska, så vi är ett skandinaviskt varumärke.
Det har varit väldigt populärt både i USA och UK.
De tycker om skandinaviska varumärken, premiumvarumärken och de tycker om designen, hur vi kommunicerar och varumärket och vad vi står för.
Så jag tror att det har hjälpt.
Och sen så klart att vi har ju också så här, vi började jobba med en studio i New York som började hjälpa oss att ta content i New York-miljö.
Och sen så det här året har vi haft ett event också.
Både jag har varit i LA och New York, jag har varit i Mellanöstern och London och jag har rest väldigt mycket här under våren.
Och vi har jobbat med vår PR-byrå också för att nå ut.
Ja men med, liksom få bra press.
Och jobba med bra profiler.
När vi började här och jag frågade liksom vad ni gjorde typ, så började du direkt med någon mening.
Nu kommer jag inte ihåg exakt, men vi är en värderingsdrivende, blablabla, nåt åt det hållet.
Hur menar du att ni kommunicerar det?
Du säger att de gillar det här skandinaviska, de gillar er, då är det väl det de gillar då.
Men vad exakt är det du kommunicerar?
Nä men vi, alltså våra värderingar bygger ju väldigt mycket på typ såhär sisterhood och self care och att liksom vi, ja men såhär, tror och hjälper att liksom stötta, inspirera varandra, men också att ta fram produkter som är mer...
Hur visar du det i content nu?
Jag fattar, ni behöver inte skriva hatmail nu till mig, jag fattar att jag förlöljer här nu, men liksom, står ni, lägger ni upp en bild då på två tjejer som kramas och så skriver ni, jej, alltså det är inte det ni gör, vad är det?
Nä men det kan ju vara till exempel i mailen, alltså i våra mail, alltså jag brukar också typ en gång i månaden, så brukar jag skriva lite mer behind the scenes, och ge tips och well-being, och hur man kan olika saker som jag kanske lyssnar på eller läser.
Men det kan också vara vilka inlägg vi lägger upp, ibland är det mer produkter men det kan också vara inspirationsinlägg, eller det kan vara Monday, eller affirmations, där vi lägger upp olika typer av affirmations, eller hur man kan get ready för det nya året, alltså hur man kan reflektera över saker som har varit, vad man vill man få in mer av i sitt liv.
Så det är väl mycket mer i den typen av kommunikation som vi visar.
Jag fattar, jag fattar.
Är det du som är frontfigur för varumärket?
Nej det skulle jag inte säga.
Jag är inte jättemycket synlig i vår Instagram-kanal eller TikTok.
Sen så klart att jag ibland skickar founder-email eller ibland jag är i någon annons, men det är absolut inte riktigt så vi har byggt upp det varumärkesmässigt.
På samma sätt som andra bolag kanske där de har ännu mer en frontperson eller mer.
Men har ni några frontpersoner som för er talan?
Vi har inte uttalade ambassadörer som vi jobbar med, som vi betalar på något sätt, men det är väl klart att vi har byggt upp en bra relation med många som tycker om vårt varumärk och som tycker om våra produkter och som liksom har våra produkter eller taggar våra produkter.
Men det gör det ju för att de genuint tycker om det vi gör och det vi står för men inte liksom några betalda...
Jag fattar, de får köpa in er vision snarare än att ni får betala dem för er vision.
Ja, ja.
Det är jättebra.
Du var ju rätt tidig med att få in kapital och det är ju imponerande.
Kan du inte berätta lite om hur den processen gick till och var det var du...
Nu kan jag inte exakta datum och sånt där givetvis, men du var inte jättetidigt i din försäljningsresa.
Så vad var det de köpte in på?
Och hur gjorde du pitchen och snacket för att få folk att bara, ja men det här vill jag lägga pengar på.
Ja men absolut.
Jag tog ju absolut in, ja men ungefär efter ett år skulle jag säga jag tog in.
För jag danserade ju och blev det våren 2021.
Danserade jag och då var jag ju på Babbelrum samtidigt.
Och sen så slutade jag och såg jag in våren 2022 och tuggade in.
Det här är ju första året på ungefär 600 000 så det var inte jättebelopp som vi hade tagit in.
Men anledningen var väl att dels för att jag bygger ett globalt bolag och då måste man ju ändå ha kapital för att kunna investera.
Och det är ju en produktbolag där man behöver lägga mycket pengar både på inköp av produkter innan du ens har fått in produkterna.
Och jag är också ensam grundare eller är ensam grundare så jag kände att jag behöver få med mig andra duktiga människor på resan.
Ja, men få ha någon att bolla med eller få stöttning med.
Så det var väl egentligen, och det var ju också tiden innan, jag stängde ju rundan precis innan det blev allt det här med Ryssland och lågkonjunktur och då såg investeringsklimatet lite annorlunda ut.
Och det som var roligt, vissa kunde ju bara ha en presentation och få kapital.
Alltså jag var bara va, är det såhär det funkar?
Jag var helt, ja vi liksom, åkad men det var såhär okej.
Men då tänkte jag, när jag lanserade så hade jag sparat tänger i flera år för att kunna köpa in de här första årenna och liksom finansiera det.
Och ville ju testa hur det togs till emot på marknaden och fick en jätteliten respons på marknaden och visst, även om omsättningen inte var så hög så fick jag en väldigt bra respons, vi sålde super mycket produkter, vi behövde lägga ny order och jag gjorde det samtidigt så som jag jobbade helt tid på Babelrum som CCO och åker på att ta det till börsen.
Så det var jättemycket tid, det var mest kvällar och helger.
Jag kände att jag ville bli en vision i en systematisk byggd globalt bolag, så då behöver jag ta in kapital.
Så jag slutade på söka på Babelrum och då var jag såhär, då behöver jag, jag kan inte leva på inga pengar.
Så sa du upp det innan du hade fått in pengar?
Ja.
Fan det är kaxigt.
Ja, när jag köpte in jag tyckte att jag kunde ha sex månader så kan jag leva utan att ta ut en lön.
Sen behöver jag, det går ju inte, men när man kommer, du vet jag har en familj, jag har lån, vi har hus, kommer från en bra karriär och med en bra lön och sen är det precis okej att ha ingen lön och ska bygga det här globala bolaget.
Så då tog jag ihop ett pitch deck och skrev vad är visionen, vad är det vi vill göra, vad är värn budget, vad är det som gör oss unika.
Såklart att det hjälpte att jag har en väldigt stark bakgrund.
Jag har jobbat inom odinne sen i 20 år och varit med och byggt upp flera, femgångsrika bolag.
Det är klart att mycket av det de investerade i var delvis i mig som person och att de trodde på att jag skulle kunna göra det här.
Men samtidigt också för att de trodde på om det jag ville bygga.
Skulle du gissa att de investerade mer i dig som person än bolaget där i början?
Ja, men det blir klart att det är en jättestor del att de investerade i personen om de tror att det finns potential att man skulle kunna göra det här.
Sen såklart att de vet att det är en stor marknad.
De var fine med en pivot så länge.
Ja, men jag har faktiskt, om man tittar på det som jag sa, först är det det vi jobbar på.
Sen kanske det tagit lite längre tid än vad man tänkte där och då, men det har ändrat sig sjukt mycket i marknaden jämfört med hur det såg ut där.
Precis där covid skulle sluta.
Det var ingen som kunde förespå krig och lågkonjunktur och hur stökigt det har varit.
Är det inte alltid så att alla tänker att det ska gå snabbare än vad det går?
Det är som när man pratar med hantverkare och säger att det är klart på tisdag, då vet man att det är klart på torsdag.
Det kommer aldrig att vara klart i tid, det bara ingår.
Man var ju naiv, men jag tror att det hjälpte också till.
Fadjo, om man vet hur tufft det är och hur lång tid det tar, då vet jag inte om man hade gjort det.
Det är skitkul men man var lite naiv i början.
Jag vet att min bror, jag diskuterade mycket med min bror innan jag skulle starta, och han har funderat ett bolag själv och sålt och gjort exit och investerade en del i olika bolag.
Han var såhär, ska du verkligen göra det här kusin?
För han trodde på idén och sa, ska du verkligen göra det här?
Då var jag såhär, gud ska jag verkligen göra det här?
Vi kan gå tillbaka och runda själv och bara, ska jag verkligen göra det här?
Jag vill verkligen, jag tror på det här.
Jag har varit med och byggt upp andra bolag i 20 års tid.
Jag vill inte sitta där om 10-15 år och tänka, varför gjorde jag inte den här idén?
Varför provar jag inte?
Så jag ba, jo jag ska köra.
Ska vi nämna, visst heter han Alexander?
Alexander Harsch, det är han som grundar Let's Steal visst?
Ja Let's Steal, ja.
Bl.a.
Är det lite kritik här inom familjen, har ni en tävling?
Absolut inte.
Jo det är klart det finns.
Har ni fler syskon?
Nej det är bara jag och han, det är bara jag och Alexander.
Det är bara ni och jag tänkte annars är det synd om den här tredje som inte är entreprenör.
Okej men ni är snälla mot varandra, ni tävlar inte.
Nej men nu har jag högre omsättning än hans linnebolag i alla fall, hans hängkläder.
Det känns bra.
Det är jävligt viktigt.
Ni har ju vuxit, om man kollar procentuellt så har ni en ganska kraftig, nu omsätter ni väl 8,5 enligt senaste.
Ja jag tror att jag läste någonstans vad ni skulle omsätta 2025, du har skrivit något gammalt inlägg att ni fortsätter växa på, bra vill jag minnas någonstans.
Så procentuellt har ni en ganska kraftig tillväxt men ni går fortfarande minus.
Är det något som har stressat er?
Det har ju varit extrem, vad ska man säga, vinsthets här senaste åren.
Alla företag ska gå vinst enligt allting och det finns ju företag som inte går med vinst.
Har det påverkat dig psykiskt?
Det blir klart att det som kan vara utmanande är ju med likviditeten.
När man ser att det här är tufft utmanande och kanske inte har växt lika mycket eller man har kostnader, man får göra vissa åtgärder, hur kan vi förlänga vår one way till exempel.
Men samtidigt har det varit, vi har satt en budget där det inte har varit att gå med vinst för att fokus har varit att bygga varumärket och få upp volymen och det är ju ganska svårt att gå med vinst när man ändå har två personer som ska ha lön, hoppen byggt med vald varumärke.
Men det som är väldigt kul är att vi hade ändå några månader förra året där vi var lönsamma, vilket är superkul och det här året har vi gått från, vi kommer att nå över 20 miljoner det här året, så det är ett fantastiskt år.
Jävla procentuell utveckling.
Ja och nu har vi också haft flera lönsamma månader och sett det och vi kommer att förbättra resultatet jämfört med föregående år.
Men vi fortsätter också att investera i varumärket för att investera framåt och planen har ju inte varit att vara lönsam.
Sen såklart att investeringsklimatet ser ju ganska annorlunda ut.
Första runden tog jag in precis innan allting blev stökigt.
Och då var det ju många som fick kanske bara på en powerpoint, utan ens att ha sålt en produkt och då hade jag visat lite proffokoncept.
Men det är klart att när jag skulle ta in runden andra gången, då var det ju mycket mer, det tog ju längre tid att vara mer utmanande.
För då var det ju också mycket tuffare tider, men det lyckades ju också jättebra till slut, fick med mig jättebra personer som tror på det vi gör.
Så att jag har också väldigt bra ägare.
Och vi har ju överleverat den planen vi har satt tillsammans.
Så det är en medvetens strategi.
Men såklart att ambitionen är att jag vill ju bli lönsam, så att när de närmaste åren så vill jag ju komma till en punkt där jag kan liksom växa och vara lönsam.
Vad säger planen?
Finns det något, jag ska inte hålla dig till det, men finns det något år eller någon viss omsättning när det budjeterat går över i lönsamhet, är det så?
Ja alltså vi håller på att diskutera det nu, för det gärna handlar det om hur mycket vi vill gasa, hur mycket risk vi vill ta, versus kanske gasa mindre och vara lönsamma.
Så det handlar lite grann om vad tror vi ger mest utväxling långsiktigt för företaget, vad skapar mest värde för företaget.
Så det är väl, men jag tänker, det vi diskuterar nu är kanske om två år.
Men i år kommer vi nästan, vi är ju nästan, vi är inte långt ifrån lönsamhet i år.
Men jag tror fortfarande, som sagt, vi vill fortfarande växa.
Eftersom vi har så mycket försäljning utanför Sverige, så är det mycket dyrare.
Och till exempel i USA har det blivit väldigt stökigt nu med tullarna.
Jag tänkte säga, om det är er största marknad, måste det vara en ganska kaotisk.
Jag tänkte att jag vill inte hamna i det direkt, för då skrämmer vi bort alla människor.
Men hur fan har ni löst det då?
Det har varit sjukt stökigt.
Det roliga var att jag hade missat lite av alla de här diskussionerna som hände redan förra året.
Det har varit på tal ganska länge.
Jag har bara kört på.
Jag bara, nu är det USA, vi började se Traction förra hösten.
Jag bara, vi kör på USA, det är en stor marknad, let's see what happens.
Så jag sa att vi hade ett event i New York, vi hade en lansering där och så åkte jag till LA i april.
Vi hade haft ett jättestort event, investerat en del.
På kvällen kom det ut med att Trump skulle införa, då var det minumis.
Jag bara, vad härligt.
Nu har vi byggt upp USA här.
Det har varit lite stökigt, det ändrar ju spelplanen, men samtidigt är det man vet med Trump, att allting kan ändras.
Det har också varit svårt att förstora beslut, eftersom det enda man vet är att saker säkert kommer att förändras.
Men så som vi har löst nu är att vi fortfarande har ett lager i Sverige, och vi har en 3PL och vi skickar DDP nu till USA, men det har blivit mycket dyrare.
Så jag tjänar inte lika mycket pengar längre, även om det är en plusaffär.
Men det var en större plusaffär innan, så är det ju.
Det påverkar såklart topline eller bottomline.
Så jag tror att ska vi fortsätta fokusera på USA så kommer vi behöva sätta upp ett lager i USA för att få ner kostnaderna för tull och skicka produkterna.
Jag tänkte, säljer ni bara direkt till slutkund i USA?
Ja i dagslöjd gör vi det.
Annars tänkte jag, hur fan löser man det med återförsäljare?
För slutkund kanske man kan höja priserna och bara justera över dagen, men om man har ett fast avtal eller fasta priser så måste man, de fattar ju, men samtidigt så vill ju inte de ta den skiten.
Nej men precis, när jag sa att nu ska vi försöka, så därför vi ska försöka få lite mer åt någon återförsäljare större återförsäljare i USA.
Men vi har ju höjt priserna där för att ta höjd för det.
Och det skulle också hjälpa, skulle vi få en större återförsäljare i USA, då skulle det vara en större anledning att också ha ett lager i USA.
Eftersom det blir ju alltid mer komplext att ha olika lager.
Alltså det är mycket mer effektivt att ha allting på ett ställe.
Ja jag förstår.
Nu, är ni fortfarande två anställda?
Ja men vi har varit två fram till 1 september.
Så då gick vi från två, alltså nu är vi fyra faktiskt.
Oj, aha det var en uppdatering.
Det var det.
Det var välbehövligt.
Känner du dig som en chef nu?
Ja wow, jag känner mig som en chef.
Nej alltså, nej.
Nej men det är klart att det blir mycket mer ansvar.
Hämtar du ditt eget kaffe, ett häckliga fråga.
Nej nej nej, alltså vadå gör du det?
Nej, du hämtar mitt eget kaffe, ja du vet man kör grejer idag, tog med en massa, alltså man lyfter och bär, alltså det är ju ett litet team, så alla får ju hugga i och hjälpa till.
Men det är klart att det blir ett större ansvar, när man har tre personer, och jag känner ju inte jättestort ansvar till att de ska trivas och ha det bra, men också ett ekonomiskt ansvar.
Men samtidigt så behöver man ju mer personer för att få resan för att ta oss dit vi vill.
Och det är väl något jag tittar på, det har varit sjukt mycket det här året, och när vi bara är två personer så blir det också väldigt sårbart.
Om det är någonting som händer med mig så är det ju liksom, så är hela företaget att faller.
Så därför har jag också känt att det varit viktigt att få in fler duktiga personer så att det inte är lika sårbart.
Har det varit svårt att gå från, för du har ju haft ganska ledande roller innan och varit i stora bolag, eller du nämnde ju precis Bubble Room innan och när ni gick till börsen.
På något sätt så kan jag tänka, jag vet inte, jag har inte varit i några stora bolag, men jag kan tänka mig att man är fast i ett visst sätt att göra saker, eller en viss matris som man följer, eller när man tar investeringar och går med budget så gör man på det här sättet.
Det är ju en jävla skillnad när man går in i en ny, alltså i ett litet bolag då eller en uppstart eller vad man nu vill kalla det.
Och på många sätt blir de här korrekta grejerna felaktiga, för att man kan inte jobba så.
Har det varit svårt att ställa om huvudet?
Alltså faktiskt inte.
Jag skulle nog bara säga att jag tycker att det är sjukt kul, att det inte är lika mycket hierarki och att det är mycket mer snabbrörligt, att man kan fatta snabba beslut.
Men jag har väl också, om man tittar på min karriär, så har jag väl gått från större bolag till mindre bolag.
Men jag har också varit på ganska många olika bolag.
Så i London så var jag kanske på fyra olika, fem, fyra, fem olika bolag.
Och sen så kom jag ut till Babbelrum och då var jag så här, gud Babbelrum är så litet.
För det är ju liksom det minsta bolaget jag har jobbat på.
För typ Ålsing som satt det kanske tre, fyra miljarder när jag slutade.
Och sen var jag på River Island som var ännu större.
Och liksom, så att du vet, det har liksom prognoset gått neråt.
Och det jag tyckte var kul till exempel på Babbelrum var ju att det var ganska litet.
När jag började vi var kanske tio, femton personer som jobbade på själva Babbelrum.
Så vi var ju en del av en koncern.
Men sen när vi växte det från omsättning på 100 miljoner till om du har 350 miljoner eller någonting ungefär, när jag slutade.
Och kunde bygga och rekrytera.
Så det var kul att vara med på den resan.
Och jag lärde mig sjukt mycket.
Och då hade man inte heller lika mycket tid som jag hade haft från större bolagen.
Så då var det lite mer att skjuta från höften.
Även om man hade en tydligt radande strategi.
Men du hade ju inte tiden att ta fram all information, så du fick ju bara köra.
Och det här var ännu mer extremt än när man började bygga sitt eget bolag.
För då var det bara ja.
Så då är det ju bara att köra.
Och så får man ju ha vissa övergripande...
Man har ju alltid budget och siffror och hålla koll på de bitarna.
Men sen är det också väldigt mycket att testa och prova olika saker och se vad som funkar.
Hur har du lyckats förmedla premiumkänslan?
Jag tänker att, speciellt nu när vi har varit i lågkonjunktur och det har varit liksom inflation och nu säger du att Sverige inte är största marknaden och alla marknader är inte samma givetvis.
Men hur når man ut?
Säg att du går in i USA.
För Selfridges på något sätt kanske gör att det känns lite premium att komma in där.
Det gissar jag för en viss marknad.
Men hur gör du för att kommunicera att det ska vara värt att köpa ett plagg som är så pass mycket dyrare än ett...
För det finns ju jättebilliga plagg.
Hur säljer du det i en bild eller en hemsida?
Hur lyckas du med det?
Jag tror att det har säkert kujat contentet som vi har skapat varit väldigt viktigt.
Vi har investerat, sen har vi inte nödselat jättemycket pengar, men vi har jobbat med duktiga fotografer, duktiga personer som har skapat bra content och skapat en bra känsla.
Hur vi packerat det och även bilderna på hemsidan och vår kommunikation.
Sen har det i kombination med att vi har gistat det till...
Vi har byggt ett community, folk som tycker om oss och det vi gör, som har stöttat oss och har på oss våra produkter.
Sen ser vi att många kunder som köper våra produkter, det är ännu många som kommer tillbaka och handlar igen och flera gånger och tycker om det vi gör.
Så jag tror att det är väl en kombination av våra produkter, att folk praktiskt kommer att prova våra produkter och kommer tillbaka.
Och hur vi show up, alltså vad vi gör.
Vilka event vi har, eller vart vi syns, eller vilka vi syns med.
Vi hjälper till att bygga det.
Men framförallt också att folk provar våra produkter.
Vi hade till exempel en pop-up i Göteborg, det var nog två år sedan.
Det var väldigt många som kom in som sa att vi har sett CityTribe, vi har sett flera bilder och att kontentet ser så himla fint ut.
Och så kände de på vårt material och de bara wow, det här är ännu bättre än vad vi trodde.
Och det är ju svårare för att många kan göra skitfina bilder.
Och många har ju, de står ju aldrig i samma.
Alla leggings är skolting och det är soft och det är second skin.
Men så går man faktiskt och känner på produkterna och det är ju faktiskt inte samma så jag tror att det är svårt.
Vem är det som tar fram produkterna?
Ja men det är jag.
Okej, klart, klart.
Eller vi är ju bara vi, vi är två personer så vi har alltid kommentarer och feedback.
Nu har jag ju tagit in en tjej som har börjat jobba som buying and hosting manager.
Men det är jag som jobbar väldigt mycket med leverantörerna och det är ju liksom vi som skickar över design och techpacks och så hår dem och så avprovningar och fram och tillbaka.
Men det är vi, vi gör det tillsammans med våra leverantörer.
Hur kommer det sig att du kan det?
Nej men det har man väl lärt sig mest då.
Eller liksom jag har inte jobbat med design eller produktion sen har jag jobbat tidigare med merchandising i London och där jobbar du mycket med både inköp och design.
För oss som inte snackar londoniska, vad betyder merchandising?
I England är det ju den personen som jobbar tillsammans med antingen design eller inköp, som är den som sätter den kommersiella planen.
Som då är så här, okej, se att man får från finansteamet, ja men vi ska växa med 20% nästa år.
Då behöver vi sätta, men hur ska vi växa med 20%, vilka kategorier ska det komma från, vilket typ av produkt det gick bra förra året, så tror vi kommer att vara trendar framåt.
Så jobbar man med antingen en design-team, eller ett inköpsteam, lite beroende på, eller båda beroende på hur setupen är.
Över vilka trender ser dem, och så sätter man en kollisionsplan för så här mycket produkter behöver vi, det här behöver vi köpa in och här i marginalen.
Och sen är det ju inte vi som lägger orderna då med själva leverantörer, utan det gör ju ett annat team.
Men vi är med väldigt mycket i hela både planeringen, i det kommersiella, i marginaler.
Så jag förstod ju hela den biten, och sen då har man ju då, efter att man tog kontakt, eller jag förstod just här, kan man behöva också ha kontakt med dem och få prover, och skicka tech back, och så får man tillbaka och så ser man feedback.
Så det har man ju fått lära sig under tiden hur man jobbar.
Och sen har jag också åkt och besökt leverantörer, vilket har också varit jätte nyttigt, för då förstår jag ju också hur de jobbar, och alla olika steg och vad som är involverat.
Så jag har ju lärt mig väldigt mycket.
Men i början hade vi ju ganska lite kollektion, så det börjar ju bara med ett par läggningar, också två toppar i några färger.
Sedan har vi liksom då växt.
Hur breda kan ni bli i sockumentet innan det blir weird?
Nu har ni lite tröjor och sånt, det heter säkert inte tröjor i er värld, men du fattar vad jag menar.
Hur bred kan man bli innan man tappar grundfeelingen?
Min vision har ju också egentligen alltid varit att det inte behövde bara vara kläder.
Jag vill ju ta fram produkter som hjälper en i sitt wellness i vardagen.
Vi har ju haft också haft doftljus, nu kommer vi faktiskt också att lantera hantlar, lite mer designade hantlar.
Jag tänkte säga, kan ni ta fram löpand?
Ja, ja kanske, jag vet inte.
Det finns väldigt mycket man kan göra inom Spaces kring wellness och well-being.
Vi skulle kunna ta fram kosttillskott eller olika typer av drickor.
Man kanske också ska ha revenue streams, allting behöver inte heller vara produkter.
Vi kanske kan ordna retreats eller vi kan ordna att ha digitala appar.
Det finns så mycket som man kan göra inom ett brand new universe.
Men jag tror att det ska ändå vara produkter som man vill ha on and off the studio.
Så att du kan ha på dig det när du är i studio, men du kan också ha på dig hemma.
Du vill känna dig snygg och bekväm.
Jag fattar, jag kan gilla det att man försöker beredda.
Även om jag är en stark förespråkare för att man ska hålla sin kategori stenhårt.
Vi är ju till exempel inte kostigskott även om det kan låtas som att det är väldigt, att vi borde ha det.
Men jag anser att det är en annan kategori som vi inte ska in i.
Men jag kan också fascinera sig över att man öppnar upp så att bara det blir wellness eller mår bra.
Då blir det ju en väldigt bred grej.
Jag ska också notera att givetvis kommer vi fullständigt tapezera Google på allting som heter Hantla och Sisterly Tribe så att det aldrig någonsin får lanseras.
Jag gör nästan ingenting på Google heller, så jag är så dålig på Google.
Så ni kan ta Google.
Ja, det låter bra.
Vi delar upp det.
Ni tar allting med rörlig media och vi tar allt fast.
Jag slår på Pinterest.
Så kan du ta Google eller vad?
Men är inte det svårt?
Binder inte det också jättemycket kapital att gå in i nya kategorier som ni inte har koll på köpbeteendet på eller ni behöver ta fram nya produkter?
Det måste vara och hantlar, nu kanske ni inte tar fram 20 kg hantlar, men det måste vara jävligt mäckigt att skicka jämfört med kläder.
Ja men jag märkte det.
Jag var alltid såhär, oj det här var dyrt.
Hur ska vi lösa, hur löser vi den här?
Men nu har vi egentligen inte tatt för det.
Det är mer egentligen som ett komplement.
Jag ser inte, det kanske som att det ska bli, får man väl se att det ska bli en jätterevenue, driva jättemycket försäljning.
Men jag tror att det blir ett bra komplement kring hela lifestyle.
Vi kan även sälja det till exempel till studios.
Det är många vi, till exempel våra yogamatter har vi, och det är många studios som köper våra yogamatter och har.
Då blir det också nice som ett komplement.
Och som sagt, nu har vi på hantlarom 2 kilo, ja 4 kilo totalt.
Jag bara, oj det här var, hur ska vi skicka det här liksom?
Och sen har vi då mer ett par sådana där visten som man kan ha på liksom handledena eller på fotledena.
Typ ett halv kilo, så det blir som ett litet, mer liksom pilates, alltså förbeta hembedträning så att man kan få det fint och härligt hemma när man tränar.
Är Sisterly Tribe, är det någon sorts huvudparaply skulle du kunna tänka dig att köpa in små varumärken som gör udda saker som passar in i det där paraplyt?
Ja, eller skapa det själv.
Eller skapa egna produkter.
Men ja, så jag har ju alltid tänkt att Sisterly Tribe är liksom en huvud, det är ju mer ett varumärk, ett livsvis varumärke som man kan då göra och olika saker, men det kan ju absolut vara genom att man köper, men man vill ju gärna...
Men jag tror mycket också på att bygga ett starkt varumärke i Sisterly Tribe.
Vad är slutvisionen här?
Ser du detta som en livsgrej eller ska du nå ett visst mål eller har du en...
Nu har du hållit på några år och säkert tänkt på ja, hur länge ska jag hålla på med detta?
Jag tycker att det är fantastiskt kul att få bygga någonting som man tror på i linje med mina värderingar, någonting som man har en idé och man kan se det komma till liv.
Jag har så mycket planer av vad jag vill göra med Sisterly Tribe.
Jag skulle älska att bygga det globalt och ha butiker eller studios där man kan komma och vara en del av Sisterly Tribe.
Det finns så sjukt mycket som man kan göra.
Jag vill fortsätta med det här sjukt länge.
Sen så klart att man blir ju äldre.
Jag vill se hur stort jag kan ta det och bygga det stort.
Sen är jag kanske på sikt att man inte jobbar.
Nu jobbar man ju sjukt mycket, det gör jag säkert också.
Så det är väl klart att om tio år så kanske jag inte vill jobba varje dag och varje helg.
Utan kunna fokusera på delar som man tycker är fantastiskt roliga och i så fall kunna sätta i team som kanske kan vara ännu mer operativ.
Så att man kan fokusera på de bitarna som man tycker är kul.
Jag förstår, men du har inte sålt in en vision här till investerarna att om två år så lämnar vi?
Nej, inte två år.
Sen så klart att vi har sålt in en vision.
Jag har ju tagit in investerare och de kommer säkert att vilja göra en exit vid någon tidpunkt.
Men då hoppas jag, min vision är att jag vill ju...
Börsen tror jag inte är ett rätt ställe för wellness, ett lifestyle brand.
Utan jag vill hitta en ägare som vill vara långsiktigt och bygga ett fint varumärke.
Sen så klart att det kan bli att befintliga ägare, vissa vill göra en exit och man får in en ny ägare till exempel.
En bättre ägare?
Någon som förstår?
Inte en bättre, men det är väl olika stadier liksom.
Det blandar olika stadium och jag tog in en som Welsut till exempel, de är en early stage som investerar i väldigt tidiga skeden.
Och de har ju en fond, så de har väl mellan fem till sju, tio år.
Sen behöver ju de göra en exit för att betala de som har investerat i dem.
Jag förstår, vi tar det som ett vi får se.
Ja men absolut, men nu tycker jag att det är sjukt kul att det händer så mycket roliga grejer.
Jag tycker att det är sjukt, jag är väldigt privileged att kunna komma och jobba på ett bolag som man har byggt upp i linje med ens värderingar.
Och när man ser att det är så här, och det är bara andra människor som har på sig kläderna och tycker att de är kläderna, eller man får mail från kunder när de älskar produkterna.
Feedback är ju fantastiskt roligt.
Då blir vi väldigt stolt över att man har byggt upp någonting.
Och det finns så, jag har ju så mycket idéer.
Jag har ju så mycket idéer som jag vill göra.
Vi tar det om tre år.
Och så får vi se vart du har hamnat då.
Kristin, stort, stort, stort tack för att vara med i podden.
Och till alla som vill lyssna på AI-snack, GM1, GM2, GM3 och olika verktyg så får ni lyssna på de andra poddarna.
Tack så mycket, Kristin.
Ja men tack själv, så kul.
Är det inte alltid så att alla tänker att det ska gå snabbare än vad det går?
Det är som när man pratar med hantverkare och säger att det är klart på tisdag, då vet man att det är klart på torsdag.
Det kommer aldrig att vara klart i tid, det bara ingår.